the world is changing and it's changing
fast
we're exiting a period of incredible
growth and relative stability where
after the most destructive war in human
history the U.S Rose to power as the
global leader
the American people in their righteous
might
will win through to absolutely
and as that leader the U.S created new
structures like NATO and the World Trade
Organization they established rules
rules about trade rules about economics
rules about Justice rules that they
based on Western philosophical values
now being projected around the globe by
a country with an astounding amount of
alliances and military hardware
for a time another great Empire
challenged that order operating with a
different set of rules a different set
of values and philosophies trading with
their own block and working with their
own alliances but it couldn't last the
collapse of the Soviet Union in the 90s
left the U.S and their Rich allies as
the sole Setters of the rules the
holders of the power
so the U.S doubled down and their system
of liberal values democracy and free
trade spread and fortified throughout
the world but when you're the global
leader when you're the one who sets all
the rules you get to decide when you
follow your own rules and when you don't
being the global superpower has turned
more into being the global policeman
over these last 75 years the US has been
known to violate the values norms and
ideals that it built the whole global
system off of cozying up to strongman
dictators throwing out democratically
elected governments fueling Regional
Wars and generally trying to Stamp Out
communism across the globe and anyone
who didn't want to play by America's
rules was cast out as an insane Pariah
in need of regime change the Iraqi
regime
has plotted to develop Anthrax and nerve
gas and nuclear weapons for over a
decade
and yet despite this double game the US
has played this system has been a part
of the most peaceful period of human
history major Empires don't fight each
other like they used to and a major
reason is because they came to
understand that getting in line with the
american-led system would mean Economic
Opportunity and growth it wasn't worth a
war fighting against this system often
meant destruction and losing deals for
all sides this piece was also helped by
the existence of the most powerful
weapons ever invented which great Powers
didn't dare use on each other
the american-led system has meant
stability and an incredible amount of
trade leading to a dramatic reduction in
global poverty but that era is coming to
an end hey it's me not in the vo Booth
here on camera so I can just tell you
about something I'm not sure if you've
heard that the goal of this channel is
kind of developing let's say we want to
become the place for rigorous
independent journalism on the internet
and on YouTube and we're doing that not
just here on the channel but we just
launched a new channel called search
party with my old box colleague Sam
Ellis it's live now if you're looking
for ways to support this journalism and
get something in return I've got a fun
one for you consider subscribing to
nebula nebula is a creator-owned
streaming service where we publish all
of our videos a week early and AD free
you pay a few bucks a month or a yearly
subscription for a discount and a
portion of that subscription goes
directly to supporting our next
journalistic project but that only
happens if you sign up with the link in
my description which is nebula.tv Harris
apparently people actually aren't
clicking the link they're just opening a
new tab and typing in nebula.tv and
signing up and missing out on a discount
as well as supporting us please don't do
that but signing up for nebula isn't
just about supporting independent
journalism and getting my videos a week
early and AD free it's also the home of
super premium content that you can't get
anywhere else like I've been watching
this excellent series Lately by real
engineering called Battle of Britain
it's full of all of this stunning
animation and compelling storytelling
about the engineering and technology
behind British military aircraft in the
40s really really good stuff or you can
let Wendover Productions teach you about
the world of logistics that you never
thought you needed to know but you
actually do because it's fascinating and
of course one of my all-time favorites
real-life lore has a series on Modern
conflicts where he beautifully teaches
you about the military strategies and
developments in a bunch of conflicts
around the world if you need to take a
break from all of the learning on nebula
check out jet lag jet lag is this race
challenge game show that takes place
around the world not totally sure how
they pull this off but it's incredibly
entertaining and a nice entertainment
break from all of the like super
rigorous teaching and learning that you
get on nebula there is so much good
stuff on this platform that is not
driven by algorithms and advertisements
but is driven by subscribers and
creators who are talking to each other
through hyper quality premium content
I'm super into it and it's just a few
bucks a month you get a discount if you
go to nebula.tv Johnny Harris and once
again if you do that a portion of your
subscription every month or your yearly
subscription goes directly to fund our
journalism projects so please consider
subscribing if that is interesting to
you you can try it out cancel anytime
for those who sign up I will see you a
week early and AD free on all of my
videos and for the rest of you uh let's
dive back into the globe in part thanks
to the usled order China which until
recently was the most populous country
on Earth has risen to become the second
largest economy and world's largest
military based on active forces and more
and more China seems the U.S as an
unfair policeman of the global order
only holding to the rules that benefit
them and this projection of values and
philosophies from the West to the
leaders in China this looks a lot like
the modern day version of colonialism
they see this hypocritical American
Empire Drunk on Power that they've had
since 1945 an America that is
increasingly defensive because it's in
Decline with its broken politics divided
people and a complacency with their spot
at the top so China is building a
competing system
in March 2023 China's leader Xi Jinping
announced his Global civilization
initiative where he stated that
countries must quote refrain from
imposing their own values or models on
others and refrain from stoking
ideological confrontation so instead of
the hypocritical colonialism of the U.S
imposing their human rights and
democracy around the world his system
would be transactional stripping away
the veil of what he views as a
hypocritical rules-based order that is
built to basically benefit one group the
Chinese system would be built on common
interests beneficial deals and
opportunistic alliances not purported
philosophical values and unlike decades
past China now has the military and the
money to make it happen to ignore the
rules of the global superpower and to
make their own to engage with the world
in a different way to pursue Chinese
interests outside of the system
and so now you see a competition between
these two great powers that have become
deeply economically entwined over the
last 50 years and now they're slowly
decoupling
and around the world you see China
planting seeds for its new system using
state-backed money to invest in
infrastructure projects all over the
globe this gives China a presence in
many new countries tying these countries
to Chinese debt which often translates
into future leverage in March 2023 China
sent diplomats to the Middle East for
the first major effort to broker a peace
deal between Saudi Arabia and Iran these
two bitter Rivals this is something that
the U.S couldn't do and it showed the
declining influence that the U.S has on
this region but the U.S Still Remains on
top and they will as long as they can
control the economic and financial
systems that the world operates on which
they do
for now
but China is challenging this as well
working with Brazil Russia India and
South Africa or the brics countries to
develop an alternative economic block
these are all major growing economies
and they will only become more important
in the next two decades since 2009 the
brics countries have been stepping up
their cooperation meeting annually
creating a new development Bank to
invest in their countries and
coordinating on various policies the
brics countries are becoming a potential
rival to the G7 countries which
represent the U.S led order brics
countries are even discussing creating
their own currency that they share
between these five growing economies
they're creating a secondary economy in
the world totally independent of the
United States we won't have to talk
about sanctions in five years because
there'll be so many countries
transacting and currencies other than
the dollar that we won't have the
ability to sanction them this would be a
major challenge to the US dollar which
is currently the standard for
international trade and a major reason
why everyone has to play nice with the
US Russia's invasion of Ukraine was in
major pushback against the Western
Security and economic order and it
showed us which countries will fall on
which side of that divide you can see
that most countries aren't taking a side
here they aren't siding with Russia and
China or with the Western Bloc you could
call these the non-aligned countries the
undecided the countries that China and
the US will be looking to influence into
their system in coming years
let's highlight the 25 largest economies
among these non-aligned countries at
least according to the economist
intelligence unit these are the
economies that the U.S is working to
keep on their side to keep in their
system and that China is trying to woo
to join their new transactional system
but this cold war is different than the
last one the one where the USA and the
Soviet Union forced countries to deeply
choose a side based on ideological
convictions about capitalism versus
communism this new Rising Cold War could
be much less black and white instead in
this much more globalized and
interconnected world non-aligned
countries will exploit this bidding war
between the superpowers to get them the
best trade and security deals possible
like in Brazil where this is already
happening Brazil is a massive country
who is a super close Ally with the
United States and yet they're a part of
the brics block with China which is one
reason Brazil refused to sell weapons to
Ukraine when the country requested a
deal they're already walking this line
be between their interests that align
with the U.S order and their interests
that align with China Brazil's president
traveled to Beijing in April 2023 and
not only did the Brazilian president
sign around 20 new agreements on
technology trade and agriculture but he
actually asked Beijing to help him
negotiate the war in Ukraine so even as
the U.S and China cut ties Brazil is
showing that they're not going to take
aside they're going to play Both Sides
to their own benefit India is kind of
doing the same thing getting lots of
cheap oil and nearly half of their
weapons from Russia and then getting a
quarter of their weapons from Europe and
recently securing 200 billion dollars in
funding from the U.S for Indian
technology startups Saudi Arabia gets
almost all of its weapons from the
United States but is turning away from
the U.S in other ways like trade where
China is now their top trading partner
in late 2022 China and Saudi Arabia
signed a strategic partnership agreement
meaning that their leaders will be
meeting more frequently there will be
more trade more technology transfer and
more diplomacy
turkey is a member of NATO and generally
aligned with the west but also has to
walk a fine line here because it has
strong economic ties to Russia turkey
also doesn't want to lose out on China's
economic expansion China has this belt
and Road initiative that runs right
through turkey and they're hoping to
court more Chinese investment in
transportation energy and Mining
Pakistan is a country that has been
aligned with the US in recent years and
a partner on the war in Terror but it
also entertains investment and trade
with China including a 62 billion dollar
investment from China's belt and Road
initiative to create this economic
Corridor between the two countries
the continent of Africa is full of
mostly non-aligned countries it's also
where China has been busy giving huge
loans and Building Bridges ports mines
and Railways all with the goal of tying
these countries to the Future Chinese
way of doing things and China is
expanding trade here too trading 254
billion dollars with Africa in 2021
while the U.S only traded 44 billion
dollars a sixth the amount of China
China's investment has been Swift and
effective here and all over the globe in
garnering new friends and allies laying
the foundation for their competing world
order but the US isn't just going to sit
back and let this happen they're already
responding big names like Kamala Harris
the vice president or Janet Ellen the
head of the Federal Reserve Anthony
blinken the Secretary of State have all
visited Africa in 2023. President Biden
went to Saudi Arabia last year despite
calling the country a quote Pariah State
on the campaign Trail he was there to
try to claw back some influence that was
being taken by China and then of course
the U.S is hitting China straight on
cutting them off from Western technology
to hamper their economic and Military
progress the U.S and its allies in Asia
are also encircling China with their
military in the Pacific sending billions
of dollars of weapons and infrastructure
into China's backyard
so it looks like we're in the early days
of a new multi-polar world a competition
between a great superpower and a rising
superpower that wants to lead a new
system based on different values the
result is likely the undoing of a lot of
the globalization and interconnectedness
that has developed in the last 70 years
and for now I think what we'll see is
countries won't be choosing a side
hastily instead they'll play both of
these great Powers off of each other to
get the best deal for their country I'm
not sure how long they'll be able to do
this as tensions rise and the pressure
mounts to choose a side but for now
what's clear is that we're moving into
uncharted waters
[Music]
foreign